Per la rubrica "amici de m***a", "vita buttata de m***a.... - (*risata di Enrico*)
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una
nuova puntata di vita buttata, il tema
della puntata di oggi è "amici di m***a"
Per un tema così forte ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia una persona che proprio non
potrebbe dirmi nulla
un'amica, per non definirla forse sorella,
di una vita intera. Sto parlando
niente poco di meno che di Alice, che
purtroppo non era presente, e quindi ci
accontenteremo di Camilla - Ciao ciao a tutti - Oh salve. Senti come...
Ciao a tutti! Scusate la preparo da ore questa cosa
- Comunque vabbè tu già stata ospite... - Si è stato bellissimo, indimenticabile! - Hai già avuto l'ospite
piacere di essere ospite - "Uno piacere
al grande piacere ospite di avere ospite"
- Quindi avevamo fatto tradimenti - Tradimenti,  che aveva tirato fuori delle cose
che sarebbe meglio dimenticare - E infatti ora sono single!
Bisogna dire una cosa. Camilla è venuta da me - C'è questo Dart Fener, è il cane - ...Camilla è venuta da me
mi ha chiesto: "ma mi farai dormire a contatto
col divano di pelle o mi metterai un lensuolo
sopra?". E questo mi fa chiedere che
tipo di persone conosca - No, non ti puoi interrogare
sulla mia umiltà? Che per me andava bene lo stesso, per me l' importante era stare insieme - Vabbè...
- Partiamo subito con l'ascolto dei
messaggi che secondo me è la cosa migliore
- Beh anche l'unica cosa del format - Ciao Gu,
la mia amica di merda è quella che da
quando avevo 13 anni ha provato a s******i tutti i miei
fidanzati
alcune volte ci è riuscita, alcune volte
no. Io intanto l'ho saputo sempre con
molto ritardo, però come si dice "meglio
tardi che mai"
... e tra l'altro lei è anche fan di
vita buttata, quindi se questi audio
arrivassero a lei sarebbe un po' la mia vendetta
che va servita fredda. Ce l'ho
proprio con te stronzetta! Non si possono dire
i nomi! - E allora che vendetta è?! Allora potrebbe essere chiunque - Tu la riconosci
la voce, io riconoscerei la tua voce fra
milioni di.... - Di lamenti - Esatto!
Ma questa è una cosa vera nel mondo femminile? - No! Cioè nel mio caso no - Vabbè non sto parlando di te
ma di una tua amica - No neanche una mia
amica si è mai permessa di fare una cosa
del genere - Che cos'è questo... -  Cos'è Natale? - No è che secondo me si sentono le cazzate, quindi...
Il microfono non è troppo alto per lei? - Abbassiamo un attimo un po' il microfono (Enrico)
- Riusciamo a vedere lo splendido volto? Mio? Perché se lei ha
il tondo... cioè poco importa - Benissimo! -Aspetta...Ohh (Enrico) - Ecco!
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, in merito ad "amici di m***a" la mia esperienza è stata con questa mia amica delle
elementari. Era estate, a casa mia, giocavamo nella piscinetta gonfiabile e lei decide di bloccarmi la testa
sott o l'acqua. E' inutile dire che stavo affogando, pero' il bello è stato quando ha smesso
Sono tornata su quasi morente e lei mi ha detto "Dai adesso fallo anche a me"
Tutto sommato siamo ancora amiche - Nessuna delle due è morta. Forse questa storia la dovremmo mandare
al tribunale di minori, forse sarebbe la
sede più opportuna per analizzare questo
caso - C'era un collega, c'è stato un
giorno che non stavo bene, avevo la
diarrea e quindi dovevo andare a
prendere una medicina. Mi ha accompagnato
tanto comunque avevamo un buon rapporto. Mi son fermata a guardere il make up come al solito
perché in quella farmacia c'era anche il
make up, e lui davanti a tutti fa
"Guarda che non siamo qui a guardare il
make up, siamo qui per prendere la cosa
della tua diarrea. Ti giuro si sono girati
tutti, si sono messi a ridere. Io l'ho guardato
volevo morire! - Beh potremmo dire amici di m***a in tutti i sensi
- Cioè più che morire lo avrei voluto ammazzare che è diverso - Più che morire avrei voluto spruzzare in faccia
Io devo parlare delle farmacie.
Se io vengo da te, farmacista, e ti dico
"Guardi senta ho un problema con la diarrea".... Diarreaaa? Abbiamo ancora il clistere a
doppio stantuffo?". Meno - Devo capire solo io, non anche gli altri. Giammi premi il
pulsante del muto della tastierina? - Questo? (Giammi) -
Quello senza niente - F10 o F11? (Giammi)
- Colpito e affondato - Dammi la tastierina... è bluetooth - Ciao Gu ciao ospite, volevo raccontarti
la mia migliore amica di m***a, che dopo averle accontato del mio amore platonico
durato sei anni per un rugbiusta, sottolineo rugbi sta, ha deciso di conoscerlo e se l'è fatto...davanti a me
- Ah anche davanti a lei? - Ha detto anche davanti a lei? - Perché ha voluto sottolineare rugbista? - Perché i
rugbisti diciamo sono una nicchia sportiva che
interessa molto a questa trasmissione
- Ah sì? - Sì - Ah scusate io non seguo questo canale. In realtà ci siamo conosciuti ieri
- Se a te piace uno per sei anni il codice
deontologico femminile, o  comunque umano
prevede che tu, amico, non possa comunque - Che cosa vuoi dirmi? - Carpe diem. Io tua amica non potrò mai
stare con quello li perché tu me l'hai confidato? - Ecco questo è un tema molto delicato, grazie
per avermelo chiesto, una questione spinosa. Sei comunque un po' una p*****a! ... Il mare è pieno
di pesci, proprio l'aragosta più che altro è un crostaceo
- Ho deciso di raccontarti la figura di m*** a che mi ha fatto fare la mia migliore amica l'ultima volta alle
giostre. Eravamo sui "calci in culo", avevamo già
slacciato la cintura di sicurezza per
scendere, e stavamo parlando. Nel
frattempo lei ha attaccato questa cintura
di sicurezza a una delle catene che avevano i pantaloni. Non me n'ero completamente accorta
vado per scendere, rimango a penzoloni con la
catena che mi taglia praticamente la f**a in due
e non riuscivo a scendere. Nel tempo lei
era già giù e se la stava ridendo di
gusto perché c'avevo la catena che mi tagliava la f**a in due... e niente
- Questa è lei attaccata a un aerostato - Come
a tutti i bambini penso può capitare di
fare uno scorreggina in classe - Ma anche da adulti - ... cercando di farla silenziosa e in
maniera tale che nessuno se ne accorga.
Bene io ero specialista nel farle
silenziose, quindi nessuno si è mai
accorto delle mie bombe a gas. Un giorno
proprio nel momento di silenzio tombale
della classe me ne sfugge una rumorosa
abbastanza rumorosa, che risuona per tutta la classe. Sul momento nessuno si era accorto che fossi stata io
diciamo a fare la puzzetta - Quindi la terra ha tremato...     - ... senonché
si sente una vocina che chiede "Ma chi è stato?" . Questo
sussurrare in una classe totalmente
silenziosa e scioccata per la scorreggia
- Provata - ....è risuonata diaciamo in classe. La mia amichetta anziché diciamo nascondermi, dice chiaro
e tondo "E' stata Elisabetta". Cioè io
a quel punto muoio di imbarazzo, divento
rossa e non volevo più tornare a casa - Ne faccio un'altra
Beh io posso dire questa cosa, l'amica ha
fatto solo informazione, ha trovato
l'epicentro di questo terremoto, 7.5 della scala richter
e quindi non la possiamo biasimare - E poi
voglio dire, nel momento in cui te lo
chiedono... devo passare che sono stato io...cioè accollatelo!
Hai fatto la ninja
fino ad adesso? Sei scivolata durante
il tuo percorso... - Ma ringrazia che è ti andata bene fino ad
adesso. Sei anche una miracolata nella tua attività criminale - Ciao Gu allora volevo raccontarti un aneddoto
successo a capodanno 2017, eravamo io e
due miei amici in una discoteca - Ma sotto c'è
l'arrotino? - Ma poi cos'ha detto "capatand"? - Eh io sentivo l'arrotino aspetta scusami
- Volevo raccontarti un aneddoto successo a capodanno 2017, eravamo io e due miei amici in una discoteca
- Tu capisci cosa dice? Io capisco "capatand 2017"  - Coriandoli... ah aspetta stava sempre risentendo
quella di sottofondo scusami - Capodanno 2017 - Capodanno - Ma sei sicuro?
Sisi capodanno 2017, ti suona strano?
Capatand 2017 ti suona più coerente?
- Eravamo io e due miei amici in una discoteca qui a
Napoli. Praticamente verso le 5/ 5 30
del mattino dovevamo prendere i cappotti per uscire,
un amico mio stava talmente male che
disse "ragazzi vi aspetto fuori, prendete
voi i cappotti, mi raccomando fate presto
Mentre io e l'altro ragazzo stavamo per prendere i cappotti parte un pezzo, non lo so nella situazione
ci piaceva tantissimo. Quindi posiamo i cappotti, torniamo a ballare e lui rimane la
fuori svenuto fino alle 7 di mattina. Lo ritroviamo
morto la terra e ci dice "Siete gli amici
peggiori che io abbiamo mai avuto. Comunque in questo
caso siamo noi gli amici di m***a - Amici di
m***a -  Di m***a. Non corretti - Però mi è piaciuto che loro hanno
interpretato il tema al contrario, che
non hanno raccontato ma si sono
raccontati - Io mi aspettavo più anche
persone che si mettessero... - a nudo - a nudo
e alla fine, questo qui è un luogo
sicuro - Ma tu puoi dirci quando sei stato
un amico di m***a? Perché se vuoi te lo dico io quanto lo sei stato - Quando sono stato un amico di m***a?
"Ti devo dire questa cosa, guarda Cami, te lo giuro, potesse colpirmi Giunone con un razzo
io la prossima volta che vengo a Milano ti
scrivo, organizziamo una cena". Sta a Milano sette mesi, continuativi
senza avere niente da fare. Voi avete
sentito Guglielmo? Io no. Però insomma, ha anche altre
qualità - E questo è molto vero, perché io
sono una persona abbastanza....
- Voglio capire come ti definisci
- ....superficiale - Bravo, ti ringrazio per
averlo detto - Cioè nel senso che io ci metto - ...la faccia, ci metto la testa - ...e ci metto il cuore, sempre!
Però io tendo quando tipo mi
allontano, poi ad avere problemi a rompere
i coglioni, a riavvicinarmi, a fare cose
così - Beh questo è un atteggiamento molto nordico
che non vedo perchè fai tuo - Mi stai dando del terrone? - Si - Hai ragione, per questo ti chiedo scusa
- Ecco -  Camilla è un'amica di m***a perché...
no sto cercando un difetto
- No ma vai prenditi il tempo - E' molto difficile trovare un difetto a Camilla
No difetti si - Eh dimmene uno, però in rapporto di amicizia - Esatto! Infatti nel rapporto  dell'amicizia
- Beh già che ti scrive quando stai a Milano, oh ma che vuole!
- No qua abbiamo l'aiuto da casa - E' molto invadente, cioè uno non può salire a
Milano che subito ti scrive - Ti è stata suggerita. Io invece lo trovo molto affettuoso - Ecco un problema...
un problema di Camilla è che
da quando si è fidanzata lei è molto
diciamo concentrata dalla sua vita, poi
anche il fatto che tu da Milano vai a
Monza fa capire proprio che vuoi
allontanarti il più possibile - Sei falso
Sei falso perché questo me l'ha detto prima prendendomi per il c**o. Andiamo avanti con i messaggi
E comunque quello che lei dice sui neri, parliamone - Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, i miei amici di m***a son
quelli che quando a 14 anni andavamo a
giocare a calcetto al parco e il
pallone finì dentro un campo da tennis
chiuso da una rete di tre metri
d'altezza, io mi sono offerto di scavalcarla grazie
a un albero che solo dopo una volta
dentro mi sono reso conto che non ci
fosse all'interno. E una volta passatogli
il pallone per avere le mani libere nel
tentativo difficoltoso di scavalcare
questi tre metri, loro mi lanciano il
pallone contro la rete gridando "Guardate
l'uomo giaguaro in trappola in trappola. Ecco loro
dopo sono diventati anche i miei testimoni di nozze - Ah vabbè una storia a lieto fine perché insomma, questa era
un'altra preoccupante - Ma non è stato un
atto di bullismo, è stato un momento di
amicizia virile - Di fortificazione - Si esatto, cameratismo - Cameratismo
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video. Camilla grazie mille per esserci stata - E per esistere su questo pianeta
Grazie di esistere - Io sono lacerata - Io
ti ho visto che sei entrata con uno
sguardo - Ma adesso ne ho un altro - Un altro! - E non ho neanche più il bibliettino "Mi ha costretto"
- Cioè vuol dire
che è stato veramente... - un bel momento
- un bel momento che mi ricorderò grazie a
questo video che andrà online
prossimamente su questi canali - Anche perché è online, se lo stanno vedendo è online - Ciao!
- Ci rivediamo naturalmente...
- tra sette mesi a Milano - Appena salgo io a Milano ti giuro, ci vediamo. Comunque ti ho mostrato
la mia generosità e la mia disponibilità - Certo!
- Che tu non hai mai messo in dubbio - Mai! Per questo tu dici ha creato un credito
nei due confronti che tu ti puoi spendere nelle future assenze
- No no a me basta, spero di aver tolto il mio credito nei tuoi confronti
- Il tuo difetto - Il mio difetto - Perfetto!...Piccolo
Noi come sempre ci vediamo questa domenica
Se vi è piaciuto questo video... Non so come chiuderlo, vi mando un bacio. Ciao - Ciao